the senate meets today under pressure to
give millions of americans
two thousand dollars in coveted relief
instead of six hundred dollars the house
has overwhelmingly approved the measure
that president trump demanded
and president-elect joe biden supports
for the first time the house also
overwrote a veto by
mr trump backing a defense spending bill
that the senate will vote on as soon as
today paula reed is following the
president in florida paula good morning
to you
good morning eureka congress is moving
unusually fast to get this assistance to
americans who have been hurt by the
pandemic
and meanwhile president-elect joe biden
is accusing the trump administration
of withholding critical national
security information
the bill is passed with one hurdle
cleared in the house
president trump and speaker pelosi
rarely on the same page
are calling on reluctant republicans in
the senate to get on board
and more than triple the 600 dollars in
covid relief payments to struggling
americans
republicans have a choice vote for this
legislation or
vote to deny the american people the
bigger paychecks they need
but passage in the senate is uncertain
with the two thousand dollar stimulus
checks inflating
the total covet assistance in this round
north of a trillion dollars
and most of the president's republican
allies have no interest in increasing
spending
on this senate minority leader chuck
schumer called on the president to
persuade them
he talked about it now she's got to act
people need the money the yeas are 322
the nays are 87. and in a scathing
bipartisan rebuke
the house overrode mr trump's veto of a
more than 740 billion dollar defense
spending bill
the president had objected to several
unrelated items
including the fact that lawmakers would
not curtail
legal protections for social media
companies and the president also opposed
the renaming of some military bases
honoring confederate leaders
this vote is about supporting our troops
and defending america while not perfect
this bill does a good job of
advancing both and should be supported
meanwhile president-elect joe biden is
accusing the trump administration of
obstructing the transition
by intentionally withholding critical
information
including matters of national security
we have encountered
roadblocks from the political leadership
at the department of defense
and the office of management and budget
it's nothing short in my view of
irresponsibility
the defense department insists that its
efforts have already surpassed
those of recent administrations and it
says it will continue to schedule
meetings throughout the transition
now when it comes to that defense bill
or those stimulus checks all of that
heads to the senate today where the key
player is
as always senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell but he has not signaled what
he intends to do
but congress needs to act before the new
congress is sworn in
on sunday david paula thank you